our thing is could we go back to this
style of summer blockbusters but do it
in this new this new form the duffer
brothers definitely have great taste in
movies it's clear in stranger things
season 4 just how much it's influenced
their writing from classic horrors like
alien all the way to 90s romantic
comedies like you've got mail we were
definitely in for a ride on the
nostalgia train now you know it's it's
very hard to get something like that
made number one and what a nightmare
considering the actor who plays freddy
krueger has a cameo in stranger things
as victor creel it goes without saying
that the duffer brothers are big
nightmare on elm street fans i wore my
dream warrior shirt to set and like just
talk to him a little bit about freddy
krueger and he likes talking about the
duffer brothers have referenced this
iconic horror series throughout every
season of stranger things but they
really hit home with vechna terrorizing
everyone while they're in a dreamlike
state they've stated that vecna's mind
lair is supposed to be like freddy
krueger's boiler room even becna's
insane hand is a direct nod to freddy
krueger's iconic glove nightmare in elm
street it was a huge film for us growing
up it really scared us but we couldn't
help but keep watching it what other
nightmare on elm street references have
you noticed throughout the series number
two we are getting a bit supernatural
here whether the duffer brothers meant
to do it or not they definitely gave us
a cool throwback to the 1997 classic
alien resurrection we're huge fans of
the alien franchise in the stranger
things season 4 volume 2 episode joyce
hopper and marie are trying to escape
the russian prison and they stumble
across all these tubes with demogorgons
inside just a casual stranger things
moment that scene directly mirrors a
major scene in alien when ripley finds
the clone lab how can you not give a
respectful nod to this movie when the
incredible winona ryder also starred in
it
number three we have to talk about max's
memory of the snowball dance not only
does sadie sink give a nod to stephen
king's horror classic carrie in fear
street 1978 but she also gets another
moment to mirror the film when hiding
from vecna if you look closely you'll
notice that the decor of the snowball
dance is heavily reminiscent to carrie's
tragic prom sequence did you pick up on
the exploding balloons filled with blood
don't even get us started on the scene
when 11 is getting bullied at the roller
rink thankfully she only got a chocolate
milkshake thrown on her instead of an
entire bucket of pig's blood otherwise
who knows how that could have ended you
have a high school girl who has these
amazing powers and these amazing
abilities and we we always looked at how
king dealt with that when we we've
talked about eleven number four
so what's your favorite scary movie the
scene where the police are investigating
chrissy's murder is an on-the-nose
mirror to the 1996 classic scream not
only in the way the camera follows
chrissy's body but also in the show's
musical score if you go back and watch
the movie it's pretty hard not to notice
you can't be out here get back inside
scream marathon anyone
number five oh so many halloween
references in stranger things let's
break it down when max first enters
vechna's mind lair we do for a brief
moment see a tombstone that says myers
on it fitting and very creepy not only
that but when vecna gets shot out of the
creel house by nancy's sigourney
weaver-esque shotgun moment it is a
direct correlation to when michael myers
dies in the 1978 film in both cases
neither of the bodies were on the lawn
afterward
[Laughter]
number six let's talk more about george
lucas movies particularly all the star
wars references that we noticed in an
interview with collider brett gellman
can't help but mention star wars when
talking about his scenes in russia that
luke leia hand dynamic really is an
energy that's constantly flowing through
my scenes with wynonna and david and
nico the duffer brothers did say the
darker themes of the empire strikes back
helped shape the tone of season 4. it
was a big film for us growing up they
even quote the movie directly when the
hellfire club is playing dungeons and
dragons dustin's line when rolling dice
to eliminate vechna is
never
tell me
the odds han solo anyone never tell me
the odds number seven who doesn't love a
high school classic judging by robin's
new crush vicky returning the vhs paused
at 53 minutes and 9 seconds this
couldn't go without saying in an
interview with polygon charlie heaton
said the duffer brothers told them their
character arcs were influenced by the
fast times characters we didn't sit down
and be like yo let's watch this and like
try and copy this but i think culturally
you were aware of those movies
apparently when it came to the comedy
dynamic between charlie and his co-star
eduardo franco they in true stoner
fashion tried to go with whatever they
found funny that day
got me stressed out it's not even my
girlfriend number eight sometimes they
got specific the duffer brothers didn't
show a lot of specific movies or scenes
to the cast in order to prep them for
season 4 but in this instance they did
want finn wolfhard to know about this
film in particular in an interview with
polygon finn goes into detail about the
inspiration behind one of his major
scenes there's a scene in the car where
we're all together and it's very tense
and the duffer brothers really wanted me
to watch this movie by inarito there's a
scene that's very similar to the harman
scene in the back of the truck it's
really chaotic and there's blood and
apparently they drew a lot of
inspiration from the movie number nine
hopper definitely gives indiana jones
vibes obviously indiana jones himself
you know it's a big reference for hopper
we always we talk to david about
harrison ford probably more than
anything else in an interview with
collider brett gilman references indiana
jones when discussing the plot where
joyce and murray try and rescue hopper
from the ussr i always feel that there
is this energy that is very indiana
jones in the way that it's constantly
balancing the tension of the adventure
with humor fun fact though in season 2
episode 9 they definitely did mean to
reference indiana jones when max is
driving billy's car and needs a block to
reach the pedal just like short round
does in temple of doom apparently their
production designer insisted sadie sync
didn't need the block that she could
reach the pedal on her own we were so
devastating because we wanted to give
that little nod but then we put sadie in
the car and she could not reach the
pedal number 10
there are at least two references to
this 1983 film that we know of early in
season 4 suzy hacks into the school
system to change dustin's d-minus in
latin in war crimes matthew broderick's
character did the exact same thing the
second reference to the film is when
mike and will try to call the nina
project from a pay phone but all they
get are weird sounds on the other end
listen to this
does it remind you of anything
war games number 11 we've got the jocks
the freaks the nerds the popular kids
and the criminals we truly can't get
enough of eddie munson especially when
he's giving us brilliant breakfast club
references when he's breaking down all
the school's social cliques on top of a
cafeteria table it's hard not to think
about the breakfast club as long as
you're in japan
or
science or
attorneys
number 12. did you catch that sneaky
graffiti we are talking about this et
phone home moment the duffer brothers
really wanted the 1982 film to have an
influence on the new california setting
of their fourth season et was a big film
for us growing up as it was for a lot of
kids it was like mildly traumatizing in
an interview with collider they opened
up a little bit about their influence
behind that in california it's a very
different vibe in a lot of ways because
the goal for california is to have that
e.t valley feel of it number 13. yes
it's a film but that film was based on
true events when talking about the creel
house we have to mention the clear
inspiration that was taken from the
amityville horror for those who haven't
read the book or seen the film it's
about a family that moves into a new
home looking for a fresh start similar
to that of the creels unfortunately the
house had a dark past and an even darker
present to match just like the creels
they start getting haunted by strange
paranormal activity that also includes
changes to their children's mood and
behavior we're sure you can guess how it
ends
it's clear the duffer brothers pulled
from this terrifying classic when
envisioning the creole storyline number
14. oh the 80s
sticking to the elements of the truth
the duffer brothers have stated that
they really wanted to utilize the frenzy
of this satanic panic in stranger things
season 4. back in the 80s america was
essentially terrified of the effect that
the occult was having on children
specifically dungeons and dragons yes
dungeons and dragons in a 1988
documentary titled devil worship bands
and artists like ozzy osbourne and iron
maiden
were directly blamed for influencing
teens with satanism though when hawkins
there are actual monsters it's
definitely not because of eddie munson's
hellfire club or his love for iron
maiden number 15. and then there's the
romance back when the scripts for season
4 were still under wraps the writers of
stranger things posted a series of
tweets where they shared which movies
they were discussing for inspiration
apparently a major film behind the love
story of hopper and joyce was you got
mail can we also give a shout out to
joyce for saving hopper from that
terrifying demo dog we couldn't handle
another heartbreaking bob moment
[Music]
damn it
we've got nightmare on elm street scream
carrie and star wars among other
incredible classics are you going to do
an 80s movie marathon this week let us
know in the comments which ones you're
going to watch first
you